Speaker 1: All right, why don't we try Nick
from New York next.
Nick, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hi, David.
Hello.
Speaker 1: Oh, I'm doing well, thank you.
Speaker 2: I was just wondering I've been
trying to ask you this question.
What is the best way to pass the voting rights
legislation without the Supreme Court striking
it down?
Speaker 1: Why would the Supreme Court strike
Speaker 2: Like H.R. one, you know, conservatives
like to argue that it's unconstitutional.
Right.
Speaker 1: But conservatives often argue that
things are unconstitutional and they're just
wrong.
Yeah, what do they say is unconstitutional
about H.R. one?
Speaker 2: They say that while they force
states to, you know, change their redistricting
rules and, you know, make them have all these
sorts of things having to do with
Speaker 1: my position on this is make them
prove it's unconstitutional, make them actually
do it, because just Republicans saying it's
unconstitutional to me, it's just not good
enough.
And if they actually want to fight that, make
them do the work.
I don't think it's a reason not to push for
H.R. one.
And I hope it passes and put Republicans in
the position of having to actually sue and
appeal and appeal and appeal.
I wouldn't be scared away by that.
Speaker 2: Well, what makes the federal government
mandating that states change their election
laws constitutional?
Speaker 1: Well, the problem is the framing.
So Republicans frame it as H.R. one would
be the federal government telling states how
to run elections.
There's a completely different way to understand
it, which is the federal government, much
like with the Voting Rights Act, which was
completely constitutional, can set basic parameters
and guidelines that must be met by states
for their constitutions to be considered fair
and valid, and that held with the Voting Rights
Act.
And there is no reason to believe in particular
that it wouldn't hold with H.R. one.
I mean, maybe aspects of H.R. one would be
found unconstitutional.
But the argument you're repeating is not a
very strong one.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I'm simply just trying to,
you know, debunk these these is talking, of
course.
Speaker 1: Of course.
Yeah, no, I just make them prove it.
Make them prove it is the point.
Speaker 2: OK, and I would like to ask you
another thing, OK, um, what is, um.
I am wondering why don't you mention how Joe
Manchin and Kirsten Sinema are bought out
by corporations?
I don't see you talk about that.
Speaker 1: We do.
I mean, I know less about cinema, but Joe
Manchin and West Virginia business interests
are something we have talked about before.
I think maybe if you're not hearing me talk
about it as much recently, it's sort of I
mean, it's not as much a part of the big picture.
If you have something where there are even
more Democrats that aren't on board or you
need 60.
So it's not even about just Democrats, but
at least as far as Joe Manchin goes, we have
talked about that.
Speaker 2: All right.
Speaker 1: Yeah, all right, my friend, thank
you very much for the call.
I appreciate it.